foreign
hey you've reached thrive's voicemail
don't leave your name or number
just leave me a secret you'll have three
minutes at the tone
hey so my secret is
a couple months ago i was
arguing with an ex of mine i was very
you know um upset about our relationship
and our breakup
and just a bunch of things that went on
in our relationship
one night out with a friend i was
venting my
feelings to my friend and i was just
very angry
and i had said that i wish my ex would
just die
probably get hit by a car
about a week or two later my ex passed
away and he was
hit by a car i blame myself for that
every day
my biggest secret is when i was 22 years
old
i got into a fight with my dad while he
was holding my son
and i caused my son major brain damage
by missing my dad and striking my son in
the head
i spent four years in prison for this
and i consider killing myself every
single day
because of this
my secret is i went to a work conference
with my boss where he got
drunk and confessed to me that the city
manager
wanted to kick me off my job as a
lineman because his words were
we don't need a [ __ ] out on the line
and he's been coming up with excuses
why i keep getting in trouble that
others don't get in trouble for
and i don't know what to do about it i
love my job
but the city manager says we need to get
the [ __ ] out of there
that's it
um so my secret
is that i think
my mom my mom told me once years ago
that she thinks that my our
my neighbor abused me when i was a kid
like like three four years old and
i never thought anything of it because i
didn't remember
it and so i just you know i never it
wasn't as a blip on my radar
it wouldn't i didn't let it bother me um
and then the older i got you know the
more you
you kind of you learn about yourself and
you start to look about like
oh you know what are these feelings and
emotions and why do i react this way
and you know you just have to dig deeper
as you get older and um the more
and more i
basically think that i remember it
but i feel stupid for
i feel stupid for acknowledge like even
thinking to acknowledge it because
like what if it's just in my own head
you know like
what and does it even matter
because what if it didn't even happen
and it was just like i'm placing those
thoughts there because like you know
like someone like put
planet back there
and i um yeah i haven't told anybody
about that
hi um this is my confession
for the past almost 10 years i've
never been able to sleep outside the
covers i've always had to
have my whole my head under the covers
it began around when my dad
forced me to watch the alien movie
for some reason it was that movie but
that night i was not able to just put my
pill
just half sleep on the pill like a
normal human
and i just was too scared to
look from one of the covers just to see
what was waiting in the corner
so ever since that night i've kind of
just
kind of i've developed the fear of
darkness but it's not the fear of true
darkness it's the fear of what's in the
darkness
so yeah
hi darya um
i feel so nervous so my secret is
is that about two years ago i
caught an abortion and i regret it
every single day because i wonder what
my life would have been like
if i had chose to go a different way at
the time i was in a
really toxic and abusive relationship
and i
just got out of it maybe um
a year ago and
i'm the type of person who doesn't
regret anything but that is one of my
biggest regrets
and none of my family knows none of my
friends know
nobody knows and it just weighs on me
every single day
and i can't even talk about it and i
feel ashamed of myself
and i hate myself for making that
decision though i
am pro-choice i just
sometimes i feel like i can't live with
myself
um thank you have a nice day
hi so my secret is that when one time i
went over to
my best friend's house i really really
had to use the bathroom
so i went into her bathroom you know
took a number two and her toilet got
clogged so i didn't want to tell her
because i was very very embarrassed
so they had a cap
i took the poop out from the toilet
and i put it in the cat litter box and
she smelled that she said oh my goodness
what is that smell
so she went and changed out the cat
litter's box
and uh she didn't know that it was my
poop
hi my big secret is that um
i never seen two pretty best friends
they both got to be
so goddamn beautiful and i say this
because
my best friend is having a hard time
and she also has tick tock so she ever
sees this i want to tell her
um it will get better i promise and um
you are beautiful and people love you so
please don't give up
okay i love you thank you
hi this is my secret i've grown up to
resent my family
growing up as a middle child it's often
ignored my parents relied on me to be
self-responsible and yell at me when i
wasn't
my brothers always got a free pass my
younger brother did drugs stole got into
trouble with the law
but my parents always bailed them out
when i had the chance to attend
the university my older brother decided
that he would have sent his
so my parents and grandmother only
supported him
even bought him a new car caused me to
delay my attendance
to save money and work i worked 40 plus
hours a week
while attending school even had to pay
rent
i was the only one when my graduation
day came
i told no one i walked on that aisle
alone
i even celebrated by myself
but that day that one single day
i was actually happy
when i was five years old i was sexually
assaulted
by my two older cousins one of them
didn't stop until i was at the end of my
eighth grade year
i never told anybody until i was about
17 years old
and i told my cousin who's also my best
friend
come to find out she was sexually
assaulted by the same two people
when we came out to the family nobody
believed us
they shunned us they would talk about us
behind our backs
telling other people that they didn't
believe us
we currently have a case open against
them
still nobody believes us
my dad who killed himself about three
years ago
was also a victim of sexual assault in
that family
his brother was a victim his cousin was
also a victim
and when they came out and told the
family they told them
it wasn't true and they kept the
molesters around the family
they still talk to those sexual
assaulters
they still do not believe any of us
and it's still an ongoing battle
and sometimes i struggle with
my identity and trust
and
knowing the word family and what it
truly means
and that's been a secret that i've
held on to for a while
and i'm not really sure how much more of
it i can take
it's honestly heartbreaking and
if this story does get out
i hope that whoever is going through the
same thing
knows that they're not alone and to say
something
thank you
my biggest secret is that when i was
very young
i was both sex trafficked and sexually
exploited
and from there only got worse
my uh situation of being sex trafficked
never quite stopped
and even though i'm currently out of
those situations
i never know when i'm gonna be in those
situations again and it really hurts
because i feel like one day i might die
in them
at the same time being
a sex addict from such a young age has
been
my deepest burden as someone who
appreciates
god and religion
my biggest problem
is that i never really knew how i got
into those situations
i always tell everyone my parents and
family died before that and that's how i
got into the situation
however the truth is i really don't know
if my
biological family sold me and
i don't know exactly
every part of it and it kind of scares
me a little bit that i might never
actually know
the truth about my life
um i don't even think y'all are doing
this anymore
and i don't even think this is a secret
um but i really have no one to tell
like i'm really lonely and i'm super
super sad like there's been days where i
just don't want to be here anymore but
i don't i don't want to leave that
behind
and i'm just super sad and i don't even
know
how like like it's just it's just a lie
and i really have no one to tell
i'm super super sad like
and yeah that's really
my secret is that i had a boy in my gym
class
and i thought he had a really nice
behind
and i told someone i didn't fully trust
and she told him with me standing in
front of him
and the way he looked at me made me feel
like no one would ever love me in my
entire
life thank you
um okay so i'm gonna preface this with a
an eating disorder trigger warning
i don't check about it directly but i it
is like kind of mentioned in like the
whole
secret part um but i was like very much
struggling with
eating and i wasn't really eating at all
and i just remember
never sitting which makes sense because
i wasn't but i just like i just used to
sit in the bathroom
to make it seem like i was sitting but i
just did it
it happened so often like i said that's
that's definitely not
normal um
but it just came to mind and it was just
it's not funny but it was fun it's funny
now
because i remember sitting there and
going oh
[Music]
my god i'm actually sick and mad
which is true but i'm getting better
i'm looking into getting the help that i
need which is good
um i hope you get a giggle out of that
sorry if it was too much
um thank you you're doing
the best work i'm very excited to see
what you put out next
all right bye
hi um my biggest secret is
i act like i am okay and happy all the
time
i have two autistic children one's five
and one's about to be three and
neither one of them speak and i'm always
embarrassed
to go have play dates and
i go home and cry sometimes when
i see kids the same age as mine
and that speak regularly or know so much
or know
just know a lot and it hurts my heart
sometimes and it makes me feel like
it's my fault even though
they were born that way
sometimes i beat myself up about it and
i act like i'm completely fine
that i'm just incredibly happy
and that it doesn't phase me
and it's not selfish i do it because
i want them to be able to speak
sometimes again i act like i'm so happy
with my personal life being single
because i'm so happy that i'm out of the
relationship that i was in for seven
years
but i do long for
someone who would accept me and my kids
that don't speak
or do have a learning disability
and just hope that one day they will
love me for me
and love my kids for them
that's my secret sorry i got emotional
it's a big one
hi so i was about
six or seven years old and i
went to i had a violin and i was a
violent practice
and it was a rainy day it sounds so
sketchy but it was
um and i guess i ate something that was
a little
pungent and my breath wasn't though oh
hey one so before i step out to go
to my violin practice my mom gave me a
mint and it was gum and i
hate hate gum so she gave me it and it
was a big puddle in front of me so i
thought it would be
you know smart to drop it in the puddle
and she won't see it but
she did and i wasn't sneaky so after
my violin practice session was over
my whole family was in the car and she
took me
um to this strange place i didn't know
what it was it looked like
um something from the adam's family
type facility and then she stopped the
car suddenly by this place
and she opened the door and she dragged
me out
and she's like this is what i just um
with little girls
that lie and that sneak you're going
away you're going to foster care
and i was screaming and crying like
somebody cut all my limbs off or
something
screaming to the top of my lungs and
then my dad had to tell her that enough
is enough
and bring her back in the car and then
17 years later i talked to her about it
she was like
i do regret it but it helped you and
i've hated her ever since and i hate her
still today
after we talked about it
and she also said that it was for
me to do better and for me to
you know do right just like to scare me
to do right
so i still later today
um recently my
grandma or recently my mom
just had a stroke in the middle of june
and then my grandma passed away
and right after that my dog passed away
and i know there's other people going
through other stuff
but i feel like i haven't had the chance
to really
like sit down and gather what happened
this year because
i'm so busy taking care of my mom
helping her get better
and you know i tried so hard not to cry
at my grandma's funeral
so my mom wouldn't have to worry about
me because i know she gets really
worried when i start crying
and i'm not doing the best in school
right now and it's really hard
and i don't know what to do anymore
and you know i'm just
i don't know why i'm trying so hard not
to cry um
but yeah i feel like the world is just
moving so fast
and i haven't had the chance to really
sit down and
you know gather what has happened to me
recently and
so i've been thinking about sharing this
but um
i'm just gonna get to it when i was
13 i basically
got groomed meaning like
the man that was talking to me
and i eventually lost my
virginity to him
when i was 13 and
man this is really hard to say
dang i'm scared to say it
i wish i could start over
i really do
you